hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to we all
like Michael Jackson at some point
didn't we
but that doesn't mean you can just throw
any crap on the screen they expect us to
buy it that's why I have some serious
hang-ups with Moonwalker one of the
strangest and most bizarre um this is a
bull walker so what the hell work with
those clips huh
page master I never watched a cage
master I did well was it about oh yeah
the the home alone kid the reading
adventure
yeah okay page master yeah what a
memorable movie that was okay by that
total lack of memory you can probably
thought this movie didn't exactly leave
much of an impact and why should it it's
boring
nothing's developed nothing structured
nothing is anything it's pretty much
just a film fart it happens it's
unpleasant but you forget about just a
few moments later it was a strange
attempt to try and get children to read
more noble cause but a botched up
delivery so let's take a look at why the
pagemaster is not only dull but why it's
really dull let's take a look at our
first problem the producer Ted Turner
goddammit stop trying to educate us to
eternal you're not good at the second
major problem is the title I mean the
page master even that sounds boring
it sounds like a fake award you give out
for a library's employee of the month
we're not missing a single day's work
we'd like you as the page master anyway
we cut to our hero played by Macaulay
Culkin names rich Oh God not another
Richie Rich movie there's only so much
clunking I could take in a year no his
name is rich Tyler and he's in trouble
because he has one of the typical
syndromes that every child movie
character had in the nineties he's an a
he's a geek B he's a scaredy cat see
he's socially awkward or D all of the
above
if you guessed D I apologize in advance
so as the credits roll we see his father
is upset because Richard seems to be
more on key
tied with fearful statistics than he is
with just being a little kid I signed
him up for a little league he drove
everybody crazy with statistics about
how you can develop tumors from being
hit in the head with a ball clear he
brought in a medical journal and now I'm
building him a tree house in a tree he
refuses to climb I don't know I just
want to be a good father but I just hate
that so much so to help him overcome his
fears we see his father tries to build
Richard a tree house but that doesn't
seem to work out very well look solid as
a rock
dad a percent of all household accidents
both letters another 3% Wow I despise
him already
probability okay you're not Al Gore stop
throwing numbers around pretending they
can hurt you rich can argue a statistics
dead here's something you can do it go
down to Gutman's hardware store buy a
pound of these instead yourself
repeatedly with Dan son you can't live
your life based on statistics come on
buddy you can do this all right but if I
get sucked into a contrived animated
adventure I'm blaming you so we see
Richard riding to the hardware store as
apparently everything is trying to kill
him for some reason
dog is not pleased with you Koken I will
smite you before you make the Nutcracker
movie getting even with dad I'm getting
even with you good son good boy ha I got
a million I am gone unable to go any
further richer pulls over to the
creepiest library he could find there
better not be anything whimsical in here
he comes across a library to get to know
him better but maybe a little too much
you're in need of course are you boy I'm
sure of it I think we need a sonic SEZ
right now
there's nothing more cool than being
hugged by someone you like but if
someone tries to touch you in a place or
in a way that makes you feel
uncomfortable that's no good it's your
body no one has the right to touch you
if you don't want them to so what do you
do yeah get out of it but I don't want
any books that's what I'm trying to tell
you I like came in here because of the
storm I mean you don't need so richard
stumbles around and finds a ceiling full
of images that I'm sure won't be
reappearing in this movie but things
suddenly go strange imagine that as the
ceiling starts melting and filling up
the room with colorful moons is it me or
does this look like the evil opening to
Reading Rainbow
when Richard wakes up he sees his
transform into a comical cartoon pod so
really what's changed you all right
illustration a corporate tool used by
studios to make money so toilet paper
beard reveals himself as the page master
master of the written word maybe you can
show me the way out
fiction hey to see where your journey
begins tests or you can make a left at
sci-fi and exit to the door by soulless
incredible so he pops into a talking
book simply named an adventure voiced by
Patrick Stewart who really knows how to
put the dick in dictionary out of here
of course you do maybe we all do but
this is a library mate not everything is
as it seems
for example the Keith section is really
the porno section
complains about that he also comes
across another talking book named
fantasy voice by Whoopi Goldberg hmm now
I got a three now My Little Mermaid
unaware please don't make me think about
Whoopi Goldberg something where they try
to help Richard out by showing him the
way through the library but for the most
part they just partaken spewing out book
related puns I'm a book honey I can read
you fiction classic misprint hey if we
arrest anybody we should probably book
up I wonder if any pages in this movie
did anybody watch any films with Rex
Reed hey the film's not trying why
should I so we also find that every time
they open a book creatures people and
sometimes even locations can pop out of
it so they escape the dog by entering
into the floor or section where all
sorts of nasties await are we still in
the library I'll add the horror section
it looks pretty scary no you want scary
Stephen King is writing drama again well
there in the harbor section they come
across another book confusingly enough
named for whoever has a one-man show
he's been working out for a while you
should see it support his talent or lack
thereof so they go inside a mansion
where they come across the infamous dr.
jekyll played by Leonard Nimoy hello
there mister doctor dr. Spock so
chuckles shows them around the mansion
and then offers them love martini for
something
oh you got me I was actually trying to
give you acid you see it turns out I'm
quite loopy and then Jekyll drinks the
infamous potion not really explaining
why as he slowly turns into the
incredible hack Muppet for some reason
so enter explaining nothing about the
character of Jekyll and Hyde our four
heroes escape and find that the exit is
actually closer than they expected so
they find a boat that they used to row
their way across the water and finally
get out of this fantasy world of
annoyance are you wrote the book on
sailing in fact I am the book on jokes
about books on their way across the
water they come across another famous
character of fiction captain Abe did
your thing what a devil of the deep the
white whale Moby Dick
[Music]
hell the Charles Manson cell to take
over the animation dude you guys have to
be a little bit more clever about your
lighting scheme
I mean God isn't just the light man up
in the clouds saying oh a dramatic
moment good way to be a wrench oh so
they spot the sperm whale that literally
looks like the sperm of a whale as a hen
tries to bring the monstrous sea beast
out so again one of the great literary
characters it just tossed aside without
any acknowledgment about why he's a
great literary character wow I still
want to read about people I know nothing
about the stories that have little to no
explanation some fantasy and horror get
lost in the commotion as Richard and
adventure are approached by some scary
dogs he's all the cats we've had today
here we just laugh at random generic
villain henchmen just seem to do that so
they take them to the pirate ship where
they get to meet the greatest name is
pirate on them all Long John Silver so
they're captured by the destiny captain
and are forced to come with them as they
search for treasure on where else
Treasure Isle hm tomato I don't wanna
fall it's west by a tree extract and a
playboy or something but fantasy and
horror come to save the day with no
explanation about where they've been or
how they survive boy I thought you two
are goners if you replace the word
thawed with the word hoped so there goes
another character we've learned nothing
about and thus have no interest in
reading about was that their strategy
going around to children and simply
saying hey kids if you think books are
boring just remember movies can be
boring too so they then come across the
fantasy
section which like everything else is
just glanced over only this time there's
a crappy ninety song to help us out how
does it life Willie forgettable so we
come across some famous fantasy
characters like Humpty Dumpty mother
Goose
so why tampons all their favorites okay
series that look like the novelty plasma
balls you can get at Spencer's give them
a point for creativity at last they come
to the exit it's just so close you can
practically feel the ending credits roll
by but we've still had one less boring
obstacle to overcome no it's a dragon as
he threatens to gather up our
protagonists God even the dragon is
boring
look at him he barely moves do something
do something do something do something
as they climb the mountain they come
across the skeleton van I'd just as soon
couldn't get through this movie the
three books tried to fight off the very
slow-moving dragon as a veteran fantasy
you have a very um sporadic scene
together don't try to stop me be careful
[Music]
where did that come from this is in the
erotic section do you like to curl up
with a good book now give them a point
for a funny line but as adventure has
trouble fighting off the dragon Richard
decides to go grave robbing as he rips
the armor off of the dead night in fact
I want to know the night story what the
fuck happened to him I bet it's a
million times more interesting than this
half-assed book a club so Richard
finally conquers his fears acknowledges
his bravery and getting the light wow
that was out of left field he's still
alive how is that possible you're in the
belly of a dragon you lose he should be
Kentucky Frank olkin right now what the
hell am I missing all right so while in
the belly of a dragon I guess he comes
across some more of ups because dragons
eat books I guess I don't know it's
almost over so he opens up Jack and the
Beanstalk which leads to a giant plant
growing out the Dragons died
see this is why I should digest my food
instead of leaving it alive to platon
scheme so they defeat the dragon sword
um not really as they entered the exit
that will finally lead Richard back to
the real world and who should be there
but the pagemaster himself wait what
I know who he is he's the guy who did
all this to me
yeah to the neg here what I've been
through Toby I was nearly torn apart by
great doctor that's what that's meant to
me Tosh squash and scared practically to
death fucker all thing why
what kind never threaten sir would you
have had if I brought you here with a
turn of the page a very short
non-life-threatening one if I had
brought you here from the start you
never would have found the courage to
face your own oh well since you put my
life in unspeakable horrors I guess it's
okay and in doing so
tryam fear and always yes like this fear
of pirates fear of whales fear of
scientific monsters you know all the
things I'll have to battle in real why
that's me that was you
I'm ready to go home now we all are kid
we all are so richard has returned back
to his three-dimensional self or as
close as three-dimensional you could be
being macaulay culkin as it turns out
the books seem to come with them as well
I'm afraid you can only check out two
look I need just one boy just stop going
Shh okay your creep value is already out
numbers do this want nice ass
so Richard forgets all about his
statistics and seems a million times
braver than he was before
all because of the magic of reading
books well no wait a minute how did you
get all those statistics before anyway
there wasn't a internet back then so
obviously he had to read box what the
hell he was already a bookworm why would
you want to convince someone who does
too much reading to really before this
really doesn't make me want to read that
makes me want to hurt people the only
way I can see this movie making neq
wanna read is by threatening to play it
again if they don't I mean the idea is
nice and that times the animation is
impressive but the movie is just so
uninteresting and boring lead all that I
think it would actually scare kids away
from reading they would encourage them
and the wait glosses over all those
famous literary characters it's like the
movies design just to see itself end as
we are to see it end well the only
upside to this will be as you may have
noticed before is that
fortunately forgetting about it is a
very easy task I'm the Nostalgia Critic
I remember it usually so you don't have
to
[Music]